In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, Omar Mohsen, today I
brought you a mobile 1 plus 3. This is a
fast unboxing and of course it is not professional. I am
just trying to show you the product available from
Souq. Currently, a Souq company operating Q-Express,
which is a shipping company, instead of Aramex. Today we decided to
make a quick unboxing for the device of the Plus.  3
In the name of God, the Most
Gracious, the Most Merciful. This is the shape of the box and Plus
3. The device has two lines, 6GB and 4G, and its color
is Soft Gold. Of
course, as we know the specifications of
the device, they are now on the screen. You can
see them. Find the GSM Arena. It is in the
description. You can see the details of the device.  It is complete. Let us
open the device and see, in the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, what the Soft Gold
device looks like. It will be white in front
and behind the
console. Let us see what we have in the box. The first thing is the key in the
mobile. We open it and see what the mobile phone has. Information
about the device. And of
course you can decode the line with it. Of course,
the mobile.  Two lines are put in it. Okay,
this is the first case. After that,
in his charger.
You know, the dash charger is fast in
charging, meaning it charges about 60% in half an hour,
and of course his USB is a USB-
C
Dash. This package does not contain anything, and unfortunately, of
course, it does not have anything in it.  Is there a headphone or headphones? I mean,
this is a new system that many companies are
following. Let us see the mobile phone in our hands like this. In the
name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. And of course,
from under it it resembles an iPhone
and its light weight. This is of course one of the important features of it.
I don’t want to go into the details of the device. The
first opening of
the device is actually the same device.  It is available on the
Wadi website, and this was the Express Inbox for Plus
3. Thank you too. God willing, you will like the
video. Don’t forget to subscribe to the channel and like
and share so that everyone
can benefit.